that's terrible okay well here we are uh
and uh and this is the this is the the
Glorious Day when we when we really
learn all about each other uh except me
I guess I didn't do one uh I've been
saying too much anyway the rest rest of
the class um and uh so let me see now we
have uh Professor khor sitting in the
background there but he's in Shadow I
can't even see the The Gleam in his eye
um uh and so I'm going to try to
remember how he conducts these uh
similar classes uh of his own I think
the main thing is that well he he asks
the students uh to choose one that they
want to discuss first and then um uh the
students are going to figure out uh what
they think about it and and evoke their
own reactions first before they
sometimes know whose it is um and then
and then we find out whose it is and
find out that uh what that person
thought about it and and so on uh and uh
I'll if that doesn't work I'll I'll ask
for some more help but okay so let's
pick one to start
with
anybody Mike Dixon what do you say oh
Mike Dixon okay yeah all right he's
neutral so let's take a look at this one
first Mike is you know is uh upholding
the honor of Stanford in the National
programming contest in New Orleans today
or yesterday and um I don't know the
outcome of that does anybody but anyway
here's Mike contest was yesterday they
announced it today oh okay so here's uh
uh what Mike did and can you you see it
up yeah why don't we also get just get a
a what do they call a a detail why don't
you come up zoom up a little bit first
and and and and take a look at the at
the fine detail and then we can also go
back and and you get yeah okay um so uh
Mike calls his program
Scribbler and um uh those of you who
know him know that he has
freckles
um uh but uh what do you think this name
was it necessary on
there what what do what do people see
here if you're close enough to read it
it might be necessary
yeah oh okay so so from a distance you
you're getting a glow of of somebody
from the distance you can see who it is
but even looking on the video camera
which is you can't see so anyway that
that was the the uh the uh the Scribbler
looking up close now you might as well
Zoom back and see if we can get get from
a distance fact can you can you see it
from that camera over there is that is
there
any I I see you're you're on me now so
you don't want to change sorry but uh um
from a distance maybe that would you can
get it from on the video uh from from
far away I guess this is yeah this is
too close now if we we'd like to be able
to see see a background shot of the
thing and see and see how that how that
matters anybody have an idea about about
uh you know you could you you can see
him from a distance but not up close
why
Amy well the lines blend more together
the lines blend more
together but I mean there must be some
difference between where they blend and
where they don't think your mind is
probably distracted by the you know
individual squiggles or
mhm
okay is there anything you like about it
dis like about it
Andy it's a really need a
need real need effect question in my
mind is how he did it yeah well his I I
got a right up here that I was just just
reading just a minute ago and it said
that his his original idea was he wanted
to have a
single a single connected line that you
know never take your pen off the page
and and and but the line would would
would move more in the parts where the
picture wanted to be darker and so the
the uh the length of the line uh
uh if if if a place is twice as dark the
line would be twice as long in that part
of the picture it was his idea well I
guess it got too hard to do the program
that way but he also liked the effect
when the line when the lines actually uh
when he when he couldn't close the lines
together so he started uh using some
kind of a a a random method where he
would he would uh he would keep on
making this line more and more long
until it got to the right uh close
enough to the the degree of Darkness
that he
that he wanted and then uh he did the uh
the color work apparently by hand
editing afterwards just took took it and
decided which is going to be uh U red
green and blue I had three three color
filters three color filters he took
three shots with three different color
filters um but then he he wiped out some
of the background but if he took three
shots of the
same he started he he he started with a
monochromatic picture so if you take
three shots of a monochromatic picture
don't they all come out the same they
had different color filters in front of
them when he was taking them but it's a
black and white effect so yeah I don't
understand he could have perhaps taken
the same taking a picture of the same
object through three taking three
different pictures of the same object
through three different filters so each
picture would have a black and white
effect but it's actually more like a
green and white or or you know the
amount of Green in the picture green and
black or blue and black or red and black
on each
one because the filter interacts somehow
with the envir you start out with
something that's black and
white take it through red filter okay
it's red he probably he probably take
him and
put oh he took his own oh oh okay soane
in front of the camera so he took I see
so he he started with three pictures of
himself and made three sets of
scribbles and and that that makes some
sense okay that makes it s okay and then
uh he he he he said that there was a
shadow over half his half his head which
would have caused quite an odd effect
and so he edited um he he he he edited
out the background of of these things um
I guess before he started before he
started with the thing okay well anyway
to get to get rid of the Shadow what
does he say here uh the observant
Observer will notice that the yellow
lines in the final result seemed to
blank on the right side of the head more
than the others what is the blank there
the yellow lines on the right side of
the head the
eye he's saying he didn't do the editing
perfectly you can't really see that too
well but there're they um it looks like
his he's got yellow whiskers on one
side um because of a a shadow probably
in the back but since it's yellow he
doesn't notice it
okay um well he had U one of the things
that in his WR up that I I like to see
was where he said sort of
um um the final program differs from my
original idea in several ways and so on
and so on although it wouldn't be too
difficult to to uh uh to to go back um
he said um where does it say this I
can't find the place but
uh uh essentially uh uh after he saw the
after he saw what he was getting with
the program then he then he real then he
then he decided that his uh that that he
liked it and so why why do they have to
stick with his original concept and and
uh well I think that's a that's a good
principle with with all of certainly
with visual things and and also with
computer programs in general uh don't be
wedged on on your initial idea okay any
other comments on this Karen you look
like you're bursting to say something no
no how I have yeah I was just going to
say it looks like he like I wonder what
scale he used to stay
true it seems like on a local scale a
very very close up that you know in some
small size
region um there may be more
variance in the density of his lines and
in the density of the color right how
did he yeah so um uh it's a he's okay
listen listen to this he builds a que of
rectangles that the curve should travel
through he shuffles it initially in
order to get a random this is the only
randomization and uh he takes the first
one the first rectangle that he has to
work on as a starting point and it
starts out a curve that's going in the
middle of the
rectangle um towards the right or
something like this uh then he takes
takes the next rectangles uh next five
or so rectangles and he tries to um uh
ex extend his previous curve through the
centers of those
rectangles um and calculates how long
the curve
is um and uh uh let's see what else does
he do and then he computes a score
saying what's the difference between the
the final desired length of curve um and
the uh and the present one and he takes
the uh let's see now the ones that have
the highest score is the ones where we
have to work on the most afterwards so
he puts those back into the set of
rectangles to be to be done and it
continues on with that that kind of a
method
um and
uh yeah anyway he has some kind of a
scoring function and some something
based on choosing rectangles and sending
the curve through it and and then uh so
this the rectangles will get smaller and
smaller you must have a way of
subdividing of course down to small re
angles until he until he gets
uh uh
things he says this probably accounts
for the for the semi- regularity of the
resulting picture it would be easy to
make it more random but again I kind of
like the effect it has here he
said um okay now comment from a comment
and a question you you talk about well
you can Rak out who it is from a
distance but we can't really do that up
close you know seems to me to go to an
awful lot of trouble and take a very
SECU root if likess is really the
objective uh pure physical likess
certainly uh uh there are losses in that
department compared with what you would
have with a conventional
photograph but there were also gains
clearly uh and in the context of piture
sou piture I'm wondering whether it be
deliberate or inadvertent or accidental
because clearly seduced by your
technology if he says something about
himself if you know something about this
guy that you don't otherwise know about
him because of what he said through this
technology and otherwise what's it for
absolutely physical likeness is all
we're looking for in the way of
communication about
self that's exactly yeah right what I
should have
said I really wonder how you read what
do you know about this guy you wouldn't
have otherwise known about in exchange
for the likeness that has become let's
they know about there something that
replaces it what is
that you he's a good
hacker well but I love I think it I I I
I it's it's more than freckles I think
uh it's a fuzziness I mean looks very
fuzzy and that's just kind
of okay it's warm
and
okay this is a
yeah
okay well we've got we've got 15 to do
in in in time so we but uh let but maybe
that value notion of the expressive
conclusion again you're not you haven't
done this a lot so you don't have that
kind of shaded control of the expression
but even by accident when you start
manipulating the representational form
and and and shift it to other points of
emphasis things get communicated whether
we control them or not whether we mean
them or not I look at that for instance
and I see a v sort of energy about
whether it's true of him whether he
wishes it were true of him or whether
it's purely an accident I don't know but
the shift from you know skin hair eyes
lips of the things that one usually sees
in the face to this this Vante colorful
impressionist kind of image it's it's a
shift in in character and expression it
says
something it's a heightened
and particularized kind of communication
that you have a chance to deal with you
very
special my reaction and I just would say
that for all of them I would react
similarly what they say exactly okay
well let's choose another one now and uh
and uh don't worry we we know each other
uh we're all going to we're going to get
through them all sooner or
later what do you think uh Pang pick one
I'll take
AAL well wait a minute we're not
supposed to necessarily
okay so let's uh let's look at the one
next to Mike's how about
that all right what do we see
here get a little closer up on this
um certainly we have
a
uh can you zoom a bit up up
on okay well soon zooming soon we Zoom
ah there we go
okay getting I'd like to fill the whole
screen with
the with that other screen if we
could okay so um now somebody gave away
who this might be right uh but uh what
do you what do people see
here fact let me go over and look at it
myself
looks like he it looks like borrowed
some ideas from um the picture bya I
can't remember what it's called it's the
one the hand holding the sphere It's s
it's I think it's selfportrait yeah it's
a selfportrait
right self-portrait by who ASA right
yeah
yeah so I guess this is just this is
sort of an extension of it including the
computer two different
ways It's Kind it's it's sort of self-
referential in the way I mean it's
computer
ever it's sort of Self referential in a
way kind of
sorry it's it's a self self-portrait
what are you thinking um well it's if
you just drawn that okay then it would
be a picture of then it would be a
self-portrait of an Neal with a computer
okay but this is sof because it's
produced by the computer as
well
Compu yeah it's a sof P of the computer
as well as a NE and what does it tell us
about about the computer and what does
it tell us about a
NE tell that one SL with the
other hard to separate huh there's say
something about a Neil being a hacker I
think that um
well well is he really looking at the
computer
or where he from I mean
well no he's looking at the
computer but it's being reflected in the
sphere that he's holding as well and
everybody looks at the computer that's
not the point it's that he makes a
computer look at him yeah he's part of
it he's inside yeah he's inside okay
there's how many of them are
there extended
himself
we got here now now was this a
photograph
uh is there something that could have be
obtain with with the photograph or
something like that I mean it it goes
beyond
U
um goes beyond that but I I you know of
course we're also interested in how he
did it
um uh it's um I uh with respect to
Mike's uh uh he said do did he have to
turn in his did did he have to have a a
well-written program did the program
have to have um good commentary in it um
uh so that we could read his program and
understand it does an artist have to uh
publish uh not only his final uh uh work
but also uh show his studio uh when he
when he does the the thing um uh well
here
um uh it it took some manipulation of
these images anyway to get uh
to get this you put together a lot of
things you have some examples here of a
of U well I don't have the source images
uh I was going to get them this morning
but the images was yeah so uh this is
just a a smaller copy this is something
that uh a mistake that I got along the
way interesting
that was my that was the first
projection of me onto a
sphere quite resemble me enough to use
it
sm all right
okay I like to see I like I like to see
uh okay so so one of the so so
projecting onto a sphere was one of the
was one of the um yeah that was a poor
projection on a sphere one of the things
that that uh you you have a
non-spherical image and you have to have
to uh make it look somehow as it's
coming from a sphere does this really
look like it's coming from a sphere
rather than take up something and and
and clip out a circle well it depends if
you can recognize that my face has been
broadened I see yeah mhm um if you look
at the original image you can tell that
um you can tell that there's a
difference in in how how wide the face
is and how much it curves out around the
forehead but um just looking at
it you you might think that it could
have just been taken by taking a disc
out of some other image rather than
doing any fcy projective
stuff okay well let's see uh Roger what
do you think kind of a statement is
this there are a lot of them
um
okay this is I'm asking you not only to
be artist but our critics here today
that's that's part of
it I never have been much of a
Critic um well we'll find that when we
study your
sfor
um I better how are we doing on time I I
got I got to keep track of the case here
yeah um okay so we have uh
um uh uh anyway I I I think this this is
a quite a quite a nice statement about a
person who who works who works in a
loving way with computers and and then
creates new worlds with them and uh and
sees himself uh as intimately tied there
somehow um
I
can't I can't come up with good
descriptions like
vibrante I have to B going going with
that okay let's choose another one we
got lots of good ones to go here what do
you say
John how about
a work our way down that way which one
are we doing
now the camera got it yeah so we're
going in in in left to right order is
this the algorithm I think whoever
whoever we just did this to pick the Oh
okay that's fine I pick
am
okay okay so here we have Wow Let's Take
a look at
this okay what do you see
Rich um good
question she seems to be hiding her face
a
lot I like the eyes up on
top these the green ones theen can you
see them green
no oh they're bright green in the real
thing yeah this
okay but you really but but your real
self has green
on
okay what does the okay so so there's uh
um paradoxes what come on say something
you guys disappointed it's interesting
she extra color of added to a black and
white you just drew the put the color on
using pencil or something yeah
so that's that's it's interesting you
know you sort ofe um postprocess the
image after you've got out of the
computer industry actually I've been
thinking of doing that with what I did
but I ran out of time it's good to see
someone do
Le commento invented cubism he made the
statement that we have to stop seeing
things from one point of view but from
many sides and from the inside as well
just the essential State and I look at
this and I feel some reflection of that
notion I want what any
intended Sor to
say this is really
subconscious is this wall by this
painted itself is this developed by
itself how did you did did you did you
start uh moving things around until and
and I just something finally took and
had you been doing it if your dog or cat
or grandmother you might have used the
same configurations because you were
excited about the compositional
ideas I think it's too soon for people
to really have control of this medium in
terms of these things to say but it's
interesting to even read them in
sometimes the shades were they were they
in the in uh done with with crayon
afterwards or by computer or um well
like for example the Green in in the
upper left that was just all done
afterwards some shading was already oh
no sh the sunglasses oh I'm sorry no I
the shades and the ears were
both so so this is this these are four
different images two different ones two
different images okay um like this one
doesn't look the same as that one oh
sorry the one that one there's there's
three okay so then this one shines
through while this one but but it
blocks
okay
some parts of you come block other parts
and some parts shine through this this I
don't know how to
U assess it the
um um
the uh the panels are are are existing
in three dimensions but they don't
correspond to the laws of our universe
exactly can do that in
art do anything respective his been
defined as a disease of the eye
perspective is as a disease of the eye
yeah no you don't misunderstand I wasn't
saying that this was a that this was a
moral
judgment yeah the uh uh the uh my wife
and I were talking about that the other
day that uh uh we have never been
willing to admit in public that we
really didn't like uh the Renaissance as
much as the period just before it uh
where they didn't have perspective and
things were so much uh much better I
seemed everything seemed to go downhill
including the Mona Lisa as far as we're
concerned uh but
okay
um that's when these scientists got into
the
picture uh okay um nice color now here
we have uh Amy gets to choose her
successor let the camera really
laugh I'll chose candies
choose Kathy oh okay now let me
see all right it's called a silent
dictatorship now here we
see uh well interesting images again
another eer what eer did have these with
the ones with the spirit no not
influenced by iser at all well it may
have been subconsciously influenced by
iser but I don't think think it's
something obvious cuz you're the one who
brought up AER a minute ago so I I know
you're know that's the reflecting
spheres well I don't know yeah but the
three he has something called three
spares too where one is folded yeah
that's right but there was one
particular I remember
any and uh so we have uh uh what ups and
downs what do you think uh uh John
comment I I was on the admissions
committee for next year's class I know
that everybody here is at least 95 in
verbal uh so
what's
95 percentile excuse
me percentile not uh not absolute RW
score here in no no I know how how you
guys have to walk word
every spell one word in every 20 or
something yeah this is no no this is a
we
don't
anyway these are the mo
yeah these are the most among the most
verbally gifted upper percentage in in
in the world so got to be able to say
something just say something about the
lower
percentage
okay all
right okay insults don't work what
else we talk about it I'll talk about it
it's not
fair I like the composition a
lot it
um
it's it has a very active kind of form
to it and it
uh uh despite the fact that
everything's there's nothing moving in
the picture or anything very it it does
have motion now
yeah
well I specifically when I was writing
the program I tried to I made I wrote
program so that I could modify the
compositional Thing Once I'd actually
printed it out so my program just let me
specify exactly where I wanted to put
each rectangle and how I wanted to
reshape it I didn't use any perspective
but it seems I don't know someone
someone commented to me that it seems to
have perspective in it somewhere anyway
despite the fact I didn't do the sort of
thing I needed using overlapping forms
inevitably creates a sense an illusion
of some depth whether or not they're big
or and I think that's the device that
you've essentially use the largest image
is the is the picture of yourself behind
it all as if looking and wondering at
the significance of the act and yet it's
completely in
back and it's the biggest form so the
vanishing point perspective notion is
not in fact what's at work here no it's
overlapping planes that are making
mistake if I may what I have the floor I
find the the medium seems to lend itself
very much to texture and
pattern uh and uh the pattern is here
the multiple image is is dominant and
it's kind of exciting to take the theme
stated as you do almost musically and
then do the variations on it as if you
were you know brahs on notar or
something maybe SM like
visha without you can you can just uh
like if you if you took away any any any
part of it you can see how how uh how
how how the whole thing would
suffer uh the the uh um the the image in
the background I think is a wonderful
touch
uh okay Kathy would you like to
choose Kath I think I think I'll be
different so choose r one
next one now camera just
working this is the large one the large
the large ones here okay so we can get
uh let's get these our dictator is
pretty pretty
OB
it's got to go in
order okay who do you who do you choose
Kathy well look like I choose Maran yeah
okay Maran don't worry I'll choose Roger
all right
so you got to go that way okay okay we
got uh
um the it's not like uh ABC Sports uh
where we where we can follow action we
have to we have to program it carefully
okay so here we are uh two oops I'm
sorry two
um new meaning to the word
blackhead new meaning to the word
blackhead is it is
this okay I mean you said Picasso had a
Cubist period
um I can't right I could you know who
this is yeah I um I know who it is but I
I don't think I would be able to
recognize her at all cuz you don't have
the eyes yeah have one eye actually one
of the right cube is is U only half of
me and you can notice that the oh the
right side of the cube is just the
reproduction of the left also it's it's
it's the only half of the picture
whereas the the left cube is 3/4 of a
picture oh what do you think it says
about
you I don't know I was looking for a
kind of
symmetry um that was my first IDE on the
picture and then I went on um geometry
and projections and ended up choosing a
cube to wrap a picture over it and then
the last thing I did was
to find find a way of
um splitting the the face into two parts
and reproducing it to see what the
effect would be having a perfectly
symmetric face and If This Were a
commercial making operation what should
the guy like who chooses you from seeing
this who are
you well things you said for instance it
describes a kind of formality symmetry
solidity the
cube uh you take one hat and reflect it
on the other side rather than to suffer
the possibility that some blemish of
something will um recur not recur but
I'm getting lost um well looking for is
some summary sense of the expressive
impact of the statement you've made
about yourself that's what I'm fishing
for how you trying to say that you're a
square or
a
formal was was was something you said
it's your your original
motivations well you're looking for
symmetry
geometry I don't it might be a search
for
protection being forced into a
mold finally I made my program um more
us user friendly so that I can different
things with it and um another thing I
did was also projecting three different
pictures on the three faces of the cube
and um allowing the user to choose the
orientation of the
faces so do I detect you changing the
subject no this is the the other thing I
did M so that in other words to make a
uh more of a more of a workbench brch uh
for for things and this is what what
finally was the best uh orientation
though after having it
friendly okay Maran who do you
choose I guess
Andy me
see this is a bit Yeah bit dark in the
TV
what do we see
here with the background gone what with
the background gone you see a kind of I
mean I see a kind of eagerness it almost
looks like he's leaping forward the the
foreground being so
prominent how did the computer help them
make that statement different from a
photographer for
instance
um well the background can be pure white
I mean it's they in taking a picture
where you just put somebody in front of
a white screen it has a different
effect there's still you see a
background somewhere in the distance
usually it's never so completely
whitewashed whereas here there is just
is no background it's almost like a
disembodied head floating in space and
there is a kind of forwardness and
eagerness about that there's no way of
relating it to surroundings at all
because there nothing to relate it
to what about the difference of the four
you said without the background I'm not
sure we have no background here we have
some here we have other things here what
do
we what um seems to be changing into
something
else this is a m this is say this is
figure what is the what was yeah but
what was the uh the thing on TV the uh
the UN Incredible Shrinking no no no
Incredible Hulk no what is it the the
guy like okay I haven't what this looks
more like the werewolf yeah oh I see
here here the the skin is beginning to
fall off this so there's are
transformations that uh Dr Jack we Dr
Jack okay yeah so we we see here uh uh
what the the transformation that comes
when you enter
Stanford I like the uh the use of the
reflectant in the last one to uh kind of
make a a kind of a furer looking
face well that's yeah it's four eyes uh
it's not just four eyes and
two
hairs
there
um Andy want to say something well if
you notice they're all reflected like
the the no I didn't okay the top left
one is is just the left half of my face
reflected on the right and the top right
one is the right half of my fa face
reflected on the left and then the
bottom left is the left half reflected
and then some
enhancing I just add some contrast to it
added contrast so it's more
contrasty related that's what those
are it it's a it's not exactly a tattoo
looking thing but sort of a face
painting uh uh thing so okay so uh uh
why didn't then so so why did you um uh
let me
see um not do the obvious fourth thing
cuz the Imaging was down what the
Imaging was down this morning you know I
mean yeah um the bottom half with the
yeah I was going to do that but I hadn't
gotten around to it oh okay the the
machine machine went
down okay so you can see that's kind of
patched
together four different pictures stap
together did anybody pick up the uh
difference between the top two as far as
left left and right right I knew they
were both mirrored I didn't realize they
were left left or right
right but you can tell a lot more from
the hairline they're exactly the same
something like that is there no you it's
the main distinguishing thing you can
tell search for
got
what a
little EXA okay problem is I guess he's
a fairly symmetrical person
so
right
okay let's um let's try
next let's see these two belong yeah
Belong
Together
me oh here actually is my self-portrait
those are intermediate byproducts right
those are my intermediate products these
are what do you mean
intermediate that is this is
it oh well the the real thing is on the
table Yeah I have a little trouble with
the medium but we can talk about
it it's it's even it's a Diet
Coke
something the aerobic
instruction okay it's got fresh
on I'm saying okay well let's look at
the at the uh at
these these images here this
um first of all I just have to ask this
was all this was all digitized with that
camera that we looked at a month ago
right you did a hand you did a handstand
there right
that picture I took aswh and you held it
up to the camera I was like wondering
cuz that lab didn't look like it lookig
enough
yeah right okay so now um so so uh uh if
we didn't have to tack this up on the
wall there what would be the the the the
uh the way you would mount it in a in a
you know
Museum well those were actually just I
was going to describe the program with
um I wanted to do something
three-dimensional I decided that that
would would be a better expression than
anything flat and my original idea was
to try to do computer AED sculpture in
some way mhm and so my program
just
um I found out it would be very
difficult to get depth information off
of the stereo pair of images so I
what I did was to take
um computer well to use the digitizer to
take profiles at every 10°
angle um of my head and then my program
took was a line drawing program to just
take the profile out and that's the the
handstand picture was to show you what
the line drawing program did mhm just
you know defines uh just boundaries yeah
yeah and then I tried to use the
templates that I had made of the
profiles um pressed into paper mâché
around at every 10° angle to make the
papermache
head but it turns out that as you press
one in it kind of gos it up on the other
side so the resemblance isn't all
there but it has
a
and that's okay now the uh the gold
thread oh that's that's hair and I'm
bleeding out the scalp my brain's coming
out bleeding Diet
Coke is that just the pedestal or
whatever oh I guess it could be the body
couldn't
it body
so let me see now the uh paper mâché was
uh so
this I don't remember the paper mâché
isn't that where you apply more layers
as you go I I don't I I use this as more
a black clay medium okay so you got it
in yeah and
uh what this is lump lump mâché okay
just in terms of technique you find
right you find that it's very hard to to
get threedimensional information out of
two-dimensional things even though I
mean your problem was that you didn't
know the other media by which you might
have mounted these images of yourself to
express even if
sunun right the image that you were
looking for uh I really have to
compliment you on just having the the
the insightfulness to suggest that a
portrait might be threedimensional since
we all are you know uh but I think it's
a Moun
issue well and I tried to take the
different the faces every 10° angle and
mount them along an axis so that it was
just a bunch of planes looking out you
didn't need to paper mâché at all just a
series of of wings of right and planes
coming out from the central core scor D
for example that could have carried
right a lot of ways to do it but that's
a technology other than the one you have
I tried that actually and I didn't I
just didn't like the way it looked it
looked like a bunch of planes I thought
it didn't it did just didn't have the
volume well there were a lot of waves
you know and you have to study it a lot
of waves but does interest me it is this
incredible technologically uh Innovative
circumstance you know but we don't have
things to stick things on the wall you
know or extension cords for projectors
to get back and under so you you may
need the backup of some tradition in the
in these areas some kind of wire or
something I don't know yeah that's
yeah very interesting to see the edges
or maybe just got the computer to do the
right the right profile
sorry going back to goes back to the
little rimand I showed you that wasi in
the way it used light and shade on the
face
remember also the textures a little
different from the
Jackie we see just refreshing it looks
like it was done by hand which is kind
of nice I mean because it
wasn't that's what you're
saying
yeah it uh I see by hand you would have
had the same sensity well I'm certainly
not capable enough to produce things
like that by hand but and but um there
wasn't any hand editing on that you just
that was
just so it kind of looks like a Charco
or pencil
or sketch on a very toothy paper where a
system of a little points of the teeth
of the paper would give that kind
of
okay okay
now oh now let me see if I can guess
this one electrical man energy
earlier wow but there's a retiring shy
person sometimes you get the point if
you stayed it in the
opposite
okay this is the way I'm sure
I wonder I wonder if the if the portrait
would have been the same if um if I had
assigned a different thing for problem
four um now let's see so this
uh uh what okay does everybody know who
this
is
no process
elimination what did you sayess of
elimination he a pro elimination is not
Amy
very can
okay so uh uh okay so we we see here
um uh well lots of motion lots of lots
of statement about
uh about uh to say uh
uh
uh somehow it it looks dangerous to me I
mean yeah
right very shocking uh selfportrait
ier yeah obviously there are these I
don't know why I'm doing this when it's
right uh there is this very systematic
caring bone of light and shade which
changes into a much more organic and
peculiarly energetic thing as it moves
across the face and back out the other
side so the sense of the image of the
face infused with of perhaps rather
rigid or or or or or system systematic
geometric pattern into something much
more lively seems exciting and it's one
of the few in which the aesthetic
condition is communicating as much as
the symbolic condition I am in a square
I am several panels I am a frisbee etc
etc this is symbolic mode of
communication okay but here we have the
quality of light and shade of the energy
of quality of the line of a sense of
pattern regular and then distorted these
are aesthetic devices that could they
also
communicate really the core of what what
art is about so that c to and how did
the how how did the uh it's it's also
has this three-dimensional uh uh
bursting
through um aspect to it was it generated
from from Simply a
two-dimensional yeah image what was the
the uh uh I mean what was the
process involved I mean you this
uh these extra details are a little
extra but but not no I'm sorry for the
whole for the you know for the basic uh
we start here with a very
geometric U you know the the electricity
is only in the middle it's I I couldn't
see it so well on the TV as I could it's
it's so obvious to see it right there so
it uh
get uh you're saying it's really not
Amy
um
um um go on okay uh basically just
explain how how I got the picture or
well the yeah I mean your feelings about
the original ideas well you really want
to know the original ideas I was just
planning on writing a whole bunch of
functions to just play around with the
picture and
get to something that I liked I had all
sorts of little you know procedures
written in and one of them was
to take like all of the pixels in the
picture I would add on the row whatever
row they were in and take that mod
256 So eventually you get things getting
was it lighter as it goes across and
then it'll jump it'll keep shading this
way and you mean everything relative the
darker it is the faster it changes seems
like no no I would just add on the row
value you know whatever row was into the
gray value of the pixel oh I
see picture would I don't it's 255 white
or black white so it would get you know
something was straight it would start
getting lighter and lighter it would
immediately jump to Black and then start
getting lighter again yeah okay so the
original idea was to do some arithmetic
uh playing around with the with the
numbers behind the picture
in some way that would would shift the
the Valu that's what this doing and I
didn't like the you know very shift
quick jump from white to black so I made
it bounce off the white it would go up
to the white and then get back down
which if you look in any uh any column
of this that's what you get you'll go
you know on the side you'll get from the
white all the way up to the black back
down to the white in the background you
can see that and the way we got the
zigzags I did it first in One Direction
and then in the other
so it was normally just lines going
straight across okay you know going
straight up and down got changed into
zigzags the idea is the background and
the monacle was just a uh an accident
yes I mean this was the first thing that
came out that way I have a few others
which I was experimenting with know what
happens if you put it through a couple
different times in different
directions well um what else you wear on
your eyee I mean this eye piece I'm
sorry it's a it's just a fish tail or
something
there but you weren't photographed with
that on you
that's sort of irrelevant came out and
and then uh so so in other words you had
a variety of experiments that that led
to to this final image without without
preconceived I this just came out off
the wall I had no idea it was going to
happen when it did and then I after I
liked it I like the energy of it I just
looked at it and said then I tried to
figure out exactly what was going on and
why it
happened en the
energy this is all like reading tea
leaves you know plan the expression but
we don't necessarily arrange the tea
leaves uh for expressive intent it's
okay in the beginning I me what else you
going to do at least you have the I mean
we know what your taste is because you
liked it you like what that tells you
about yourself and and he he kept
manipul relating it to to to more of the
same after after the right but this is
the first one that came out that way
mhm I guess oh I see then afterwards
afterwards I played around with other I
didn't like the effects quite as
much I guess a lot of it was just the
you surprise at the first one I liked it
afterwards I started to be able to
predict a little bit more what what was
going to come out and I wasn't quite as
surprised by him I wasn't quite as
excited about him because of that mhm
I
see okay has something to do with it
good how are we doing on
time oh okay that's a shame um let's
move to the next yeah let's move to the
okay I'll I'll pick Rogers
next this is a not an ad for Cola is
that right but
for yeah Roger Roger crew his name is a
a uh the bottom one was sort of intended
to be the final one but after I printed
it out I think I
well I like both of them I don't know I
um essentially what what I what I had
was a um well my original idea was just
to have a have a program that
would draw draw lines and and and just
draw the different features of the face
in in lines and then move them around as
with um that that character program that
we saw remember a couple weeks
back and then I you know I basically set
up a an editing type program to to make
what systematic dis just to just to just
just to display an image and then draw
lines on top of it and then I was
figuring I could do something with the
lines and when I when I did that I
discovered the lines looked really bad
and and then I realized well why not
just take pieces of the original
picture um and so then I mean the heart
of that is just a fill a fill
algorithm so I draw a little shape on
the screen and then it copies that part
of the raster to any section of the
screen that I want
to so the top one was just playing
around
and I move the to the top one now
camera the top top one is essentially I
had two image one two images one was
just a basic a half tone of the original
picture which is what's in the
background on the
bottom and then another one that I got
from differencing neighboring
pixels s of taking a PL in so what's
this here this this
upet that that's a small that's a
section out of the background with the
half tone Oh
really but essentially so what happened
was I like the way the beard and the
hair came out on the the laian
image and so
I I figured I'd take the beard and the
hair from the second image well not I
mean from the Lan and then the fa the
rest of the face from the original
image and put them
together and and then I discovered this
that that was the first try which I
don't have a copy of so so the bottom
one you say is your is somehow the final
bottom one was produced last yeah this
and it it's the it's the the real you
standing out in the
crowd of prot
imposters
this is uh this is
you you like
lus transform if not his philosophy or
something I I I see an enthusiasm for
the flavor and unique character of the
medium and the portrait he features
against the others where the medium is
soft played and produces a half tone
similar to that we get from other
reproductive media that the dominant
head is the one where the texture of uh
the image is is most ofur the uniqueness
most featured I think is a significant
about yeah it could have been the other
way around I mean you would
conventionally expect that the dominant
head would be the most model and the
most real and that the background would
fragment and vibrate but that you
reverse indeed and it does it it does
become more
prominent uh
um not sure about the shades but well
what happened was as I put the beard on
the hair on and then I borrowed the nose
from my real from the real picture and I
realiz the one thing the one problem
with the real picture is that the eyes
were sort of closed and I say well let's
put some sunglasses on this and see what
it looks like so the high contrast
against the white of the face gives it a
central dominance that works actually
the face has been removed yeah there's
no
face just
yeah okay hey guys this is my last
office hour of the year of the of the
ter I've got to
see okay well we really appreciate it
that you you sorry not to see the others
time discuss thank you thank you thanks
very
much here we have
um your friend and mine
right so now when we talked about the
first day I I remember a lot of
bicyclists but was there also what other
sports did were brought up at that time
this this
is this is somebody throwing himself at
us is this
right
is there really no face on the on the
image it's been softened it's been
softened it's been taken off and
put but yeah was this is this also you
yeah from a photograph or from from uh
being in Cedar Hall did you have the
idea in mind of the final thing when you
when you digitize the picture or was
that yeah I said that was a photo the
back it's wonderful now is there some
reason you're looking back at yourself
at where you came
from yeah that's the that's the Gaze is
looking
back yeah that's really the the uh the
most
uh uh provoc ative aspect of the of the
thing the uh isn't it the way the uh I
mean it it it it's almost too that's
what I that's why I guess I asked my
question and it was uh it it it it came
out so well at the end that I I could
hardly believe that it was all thought
of in advance to such to such levels of
detail things that good are only the
result of
serendipity
hours
hours I guess I was trying to have the
the face on the Frisbee looked kind of
confused so that's why I was looking
back to see what where it was coming
from doesn't really look confused look
like it's sort of half smiling at the
fure actually yeah I had another image
that was more
confused I see cuz the angle of the
Frisbee and the and definitely the
expression on the Frisbee's face would
really change the whole character I
think you know if you were looking out
more if the Frisbee
was you know what I mean sort of sailing
out like you were
heading out into the Galaxy or
something say was asking who's this
G yeah but it's it you know it shows a a
uh also an excitement for uh motion and
things like that as well as a yeah it's
a it's it's not confused in this one
it's sort of uh uh sort of that feels
good
type
of and then the uh the hairline is
different in the back
there a different there a different
picture different
picture more
comments okay let's
see um
now we
have well wait a minute what are these
fangs okay
so um
Fang
Fang this just just as the precursor oh
okay let's put this up
oh excuse
me are you going to send this
home
I got I
got okay so now there's something
um a bit devilish about this
character is just how you say yourself
this is he was the first he was the only
one who said yes I have an idea it was
the first day when we but that this
wasn't the idea this wasn't the
idea okay
um and uh so so the uh uh the one on the
bottom was a precursor you say of your
thing wa these are the largest images
that we that anybody was able to get out
you got this out of the same machine as
the others without
breaking this is on the door on the
Raven on the what Raven That's oh I see
no you're over at
HPP
okay
um all right
um uh more comments okay what do you
think of this our I ask our visitor to
speak here no embarrass well it's kind
of
weird the bullseye effect layered on top
of everything else and it kind of makes
it very yeah yeah
um I want to say surrealistic by the
time you get to the end of it it just
doesn't I look at it and I kind of go
well what is he trying to portray I mean
it's it's centering yeah the ey is is a
is certainly a supposed to be a center
Central aspect but is it it but things
are competing with each other yeah it's
it's real busy too much uh over over
sensory
the ey is uh is hyp is Hypnotic but the
uh but the the other parts seem to be
also wanting
to to
come come to the Flor just seems like
sort of an evil picture I just the
epitome of evil is this
like that was a general idea you you you
decided that you were going to put the
kabash on this whole idea of a
self-portrait No More Mr
guy Everyone likes this is this is the
one that was influenced by problem for
the
most well um I
see um no actually uh um he comes
through as a rather lovable uh
devil that's
true yeah but looks more like a pirate
in no sense somehow I don't know
why patch effect from your yeah it
started off as a thing in the
back yeah started off it started off as
a pirate uh went on to uh become a devil
and later I think a
vampire I I don't know the idea was
simply an image of
uh wickedness or whatever it
is not particular image
of okay well combined all the images of
wickedness you could think of
and uh he got
something so it's the most it's the most
honest self-portrait of
the the problem with portraying a
wickedness though is the smile in the
middle of it I mean it just it it
somehow doesn't work you know that's
right yeah there were too many things
tried it that without sort of deciding
on the S on the on on one of them to be
to be the master it's probably it's
probably the the the trouble is it's
making too many statements done and they
cancel I think a little bit no I it
comes across to me as kind of
intentionally comical that you you kind
of have a re standing there and then
there are all these things thrown
on I thought the the the total effect
was kind of comic kind of matched his
personality okay
so anybody else want to to get into The
Fray
here okay so uh uh the uh the uh the in
other words uh uh the humor is the is is
really the predominant thing that comes
out of it in the end yeah I these are
very kind of super icial symbols of
wickedness right yeah they're kind
of over overly cliche okay wickedness
all right I see a good guy trying to be
Wicked trying trying to prend to be
Wicked he's got guy uhhuh yeah okay now
we're getting
there and um and then uh uh use of
uh of uh square of ax^2 + B
y^2
to
uh not sure that that
was that added to the effect of of humor
to my could have but it was it more of a
interesting hack while the bottom one
okay let's go on to the next um and here
we
have
well well must be the it must be our
other four eyes here but uh
um but but two to the end I
way yeah but this looks like somebody
else What's Happening Here somebody else
yeah you know I know this guy he I used
to know him in Southern
California uh with that I told you it
didn't look like
you well and
well so that's what I'm trying to trying
to uh um go to
what yep yeah it's see all
right and U okay so now we have the uh
um okay the multiple this
is
um uh okay I'm met a loss on uh this one
I certainly see that
it's that it's uh it's this friend of
mine and and somehow even though the
friend only had four eyes um but uh but
what is the but what are the use of
textures and and so on in this
what ESS it's a merge of three pictures
mhm uh the one in the middle is the a
symmetric
sum of the two U of the original picture
plus this
reflect okay so the one in the middle
is you said it was taken as as
the it's a between what do you say
symmetric sum though that means um that
you average not exactly but it's same
thing I have the oral picture and I have
the reflection of it m and I there some
uh potential addition superposition of
the treating those pixels as force
fields
okay and that's that gives you this what
the central stripe no that give me a a
picture and I and I match somehow past
them
together
okay so then you get this effect of uh
of looking through like it was a the
beads or something uh in a in a in a
um it's supposed to be three heads
linked together three heads linked
together as or just yeah right part of
the thing
right okay and now does this
Express
uh uh something about your you have you
have multi multifaceted
uh what was it doesn't Express the the
the fact that I need some
sleep you so St you say could get all
the work done still get some sleep okay
this is probably about how you feel
right
now okay well um uh and uh last but not
least we have actually another after
that oh okay second last but not second
least we
have very interesting sequence are these
These are to be thought of as one one or
four they're different views of the same
thing oh
okay so so you you get your chance to to
to stack them uh uh
it's just it's just it's just how you
look at them it
depend the actual objects are as you
would see them in space or in up left
hand corner and if you look at them from
one angle you see you see the image on
the right upper right depending on what
you look at how
neat so this is what so you're looking
at it this way you think you see just an
you think you seeing something different
from that yeah and uh uh then if you
look at them
from the
top no the lower left is from the top
this is from the top right you got you
got images on the top of these blocks
too right and on the bottom that and but
those images on the top are completely
hidden in the in the first VI right
because you're just looking straight on
the upper right
uhuh and then the lower right is just
closer up uh straight on front view but
you see some of the bottom also of the
top block well this one is this the
picture of my friend in Southern
California again no I
just but the the actually the top of the
head on the lower right is uh the what
looks like the top of the head is
actually the bottom of the block the top
block the top block folds under you got
the image here so you got the same image
on all four sides of each block Yeah
well yeah
oh okay so each block has the has
the okay so that's why these are just
mounted
right okay very interesting way to to
give I mean um we um are seen in the uh
a three-dimensional object in in
different uh projections uh and um this
reminds me a little bit of the
what was it in good or by the uh the GB
symb the GB symbols yeah
right do I got one more to put up
here that's interesting because it makes
a statement about the fact that that's
what I yeah that
you you don't know I mean just by
looking at something at two-dimensional
view you don't know what it really is in
three space or
um just kind of looking at the face of
the man you can't be sure what really
the whole picture
is okay so the statement it makes about
Rick is that your first impressions are
misleading this
right there's more that meets the
eye yeah okay okay now now here we have
something that says the long and level
Sands stretch far
away there was a problem with printers
um it's supposed to be a face blowing
away in sand and the last image is
supposed to look like a sandom but I
couldn't point it out because the oh you
have you there was four there was a
fourth one I think I saw it I saw
something like it coming out of the
printer last week M yeah oh okay so this
is it's it's a a progression to uh uh uh
aging sort of a thing is that right but
getting more and more uh
uh
uh okay so how do you take how do you
you chip it away sort of like a cellular
lomer similar to a cellular lomer but
each pixel moves based on the slope of
the area each picture move each each
little pixel moves based on the SL slope
of the area surrounding it and the wind
coming something like The Game of Life
or something like that so it's so it's
just oh I see so the shifting
sound oh
okay so that's kind of like the
simulations they do of um erosion on on
a mountain so you've just ered your face
oh okay so so we we see it as an
animation uh uh some
sometimes and uh giving us some
statement about time and uh uh
well archival quality material okay so
um this is what happens to you after you
come to stand for day we're always
giving encouragement to our visitor
who's looking us over here accelerated
deterioration okay well uh uh I now I I
know you all even better and uh um well
let's see I got to we got to decide
where to uh where where to exhibit these
uh um um these things but uh I guess as
far as the the class is concerned yeah
we can handle that after class so uh uh
now it's time for me to make my my
closing remark for this marvelous class
and all I can say is uh it's been one of
the greatest of my life I mean I really
enjoy teaching this and I can't wait
till 2 years to to do it again um uh
even though we didn't solve problems
before um I have the the feeling that we
that we did U as much as
uh okay I think I had the feeling that
we did uh uh uh have as have uh
especially good sessions and uh that we
that uh at least at least I learned
something if if none of you did and I
think that that you might also think
that there was something good came out
of this this quarter
uh ignoring
the ignoring the uh um the the Sleep
aspect uh other than
that other than that I think it yeah
right right yeah okay so this is a
thrill for me to see these portraits I
want to keep seeing
them
Arie um Anil excuse me I'll get to know
you pretty
soon Dimitri had the idea that um do ha
that you know in the back of in the back
of the cs24 notes traditionally have
been the pictures of the people I should
have our self-portraits there instead
yeah right yeah cuz these are these
should should reproduce well but that
just reminded me something Demitri to me
didn't get to make a
good was it a problem with Hardware oh
no problem of time
rather okay um
well we have a CS report coming out if
you have time to finish it before
then that would be good okay so pretty
much uh I just want to thank you all for
the U uh for the stimulating time on
each of the first three problems the the
outcome was much more than I would have
ever dreamed uh before I set the problem
and uh on the fourth one was just tough
problem didn't know didn't know that and
and again on the on the fifth one you've
uh certainly exceeded my expectations so
thanks thanks to all of you that's
it
for